- But tell us how, so
why did you adopt first?
Your adopted first, right?
- We did.
I'd always talked about
adopting my whole life.
My mom is actually adopted
and I just thought it was really cool.
And so we talked about it off and on,
but it wasn't something
that we had sat down
and had like a full on
adoption conversation.
And then I was in Uganda in 2016.
- Yeah.
- And I had a picture of
one of the babies there,
and I had shared it on social media.
And when I finally got to
FaceTime him that night,
I was telling him our story
and I was like, "Babe,
we know so many people
"who are trying to adopt right now
"and this little girl
needs a forever home."
And I was like so moved.
I mean, the second I touched
her it was like electric.
And I was like, "Oh my word.
"This little girl has
just taken my heart."
And I was like,
"Honey, we've got to find
her her forever home,
"like I know that's why I'm here,
"is to get this girl to her home."
And--
- Oh my God, okay.
(all laugh)
That totally opered me
just now like, okay.
I did my own makeup and, I
mean, this is not waterproof.
(laughs)
Like, it's so beautiful
'cause I know that feeling
because I'm only, you
touch me, you hold to me.
It doesn't matter if it's yours or not.
We're a blended family in your life.
This is my purpose.
It's such a powerful thing.
- Yeah, for sure.
- So how did that turn
into y'all adopting?
- Well, just out of the blue.
- When I talked to her
on the phone that night
and she said that we need to
find her a home, I literally...
It was after a concert
and I was going to bed
and I was like, "Well, bring her home."
And I don't fully remember even saying it.
Like it was like such a
spiritual thing for me
that it just came out of my body,
and then literally two
weeks after we were having,
you know, home assessments and talking
to adoption agencies and...